- Thank you. What a lovely welcome.
And to see you here live in the studio.
- I know, I don't even
know if you remember this,
but first one we met,
it was actually on a red carpet.
- I know.
- It was very quick.
- We bumped into each other
- Yes.
- and we were both in awe of each other.
- And I literally was like,
"Is that how we were supposed to come out?
Was I supposed to look like that?
Were we all supposed to look like?"
You looked unbelievably gorgeous.
Anyway, I just remember
you being so kind as well.
- Oh.
- But I wanna say Merry Christmas.
We are decorated for Christmas.
- I'm telling you, I'm with you.
I'm a huge Christmas-
- Me too.
- I love it.
I love it, I love it.
- Oh, my god.
Would you ever make
like a Christmas album?
Have you ever done anything like that,
- With you I would.
- because you sing so well.
(Kelly inhaling sharply)
Fine.
- I'll come and sing with
you any day of the week.
- Don't offer.
(audience cheering)
Well, you have such a
beautiful voice and I was like,
"If you love Christmas,
I love Christmas too."
So, how's the family doing though?
What do y'all do for Christmas?
- They're doing great.
Well, actually, Michael has been in France
for what seems like a lifetime,
shooting a really great project,
but been over there.
So, the kids and I actually
surprised him for Thanksgiving.
He didn't, he had no idea.
- Oh, that's cool.
- And Carys, my daughter,
flew from the East coast.
I was here with my son.
We flew here, got in through the hotel
under the cover of night.
He came home from work and there we were.
It was one of those,
I thought he was gonna have a heart attack
for a moment there.
He kind of stumbled back and went,
"Oh, my god," and started crying.
- Oh.
- It was one of those
great, great, great moments.
- Oh, I love that.
I love a good surprise.
Well, speaking of
presents, you and Michael,
y'all share a birthday,
which I did not know.
- Yes.
- And you always have 25 on,
- 25.
- you always put 25
right on the-
- Yeah, well,
we're 25 years, 25th.
25 years difference, I
have to remind people.
- Yeah.
- And-
- You've been together for like 22?
- 25, yeah.
- 25 years.
- Married 22.
- Yeah.
- So yeah, so 25.
Oh, there we are.
Well, aw.
(audience cheering)
Well, you know what?
He's been working like
every hour that God gave,
but it just happened to coincide
that the week of our birthday
he had five days off.
- Yeah.
- So, it was like,
"What are we gonna do for the five days?"
And we both like golf.
And I was like, "I don't
really wanna play golf.
I wanna, I'm gonna go somewhere fabulous."
- Yeah.
- And so he mentioned a few places.
I'm going, "This is your
choice, darling. Your choice.
You're working, your choice."
And then he said, "You wanna
go to Morocco, don't you?"
I went, "Yeah."
(Kelly laughing)
And he went, "Okay."
So, we bucketed to Morocco
and we had a five days,
a wonderful time.
It was wonderful.
But you know what, it's
really interesting,
because when you share the same birthday,
when we were dating,
it was the coolest thing ever.
- Yeah.
- I get 10 years on.
I said, "I get a little pissy about it."
(Kelly laughing)
You know, I'm like, "First of all,
it's like,
- I want my own day.
- what am I gonna buy him?"
First of all, it's like, and then he said,
"What am I gonna, anyway."
But we always have fun.
- Yeah.
- And we had, we spent
it this year together.
- Oh, that's lovely.
Well, you're big on saying, "Marriages,
it only goes well when you
have two bathrooms," right?
You have your own bathroom?
- Yeah.
- I second this,
because I don't know
what it is about dudes.
Why is their hair everywhere?
- Yeah, toothpaste tops off.
- Toothpaste is,
what's happening?
- But you know what?
It doesn't have to be a bathroom.
- The sink is dirty.
- It's a bit grandiose,
"Oh, we need our own bathrooms."
It just, I'm all for man caves,
girl caves.
- Yeah, your own space.
- Go and potter with the
hot rod in the garage.
(all laughing)
Go plant a few herbs in the garden.
(Catherine growling)
- Yeah.
- You know,
because it does, if you spend any amount
of time with anybody at work,
and you need a little space, you know?
- Yeah.
- But I do, for me, the
bathroom is more of a sanctuary.
It's not just,
- Me too.
- brushing my teeth and brushing my hair.
- It's a whole routine.
- It's the candles, it's the bath,
it's the creams,
it's the lotions, you know,
- It's the salts
you put in there.
- And I feel much happier
after I come out there
without any intrusion.
- Yeah.
- You can do whatever you want. Yes.
(adience cheering)
I am 100% for this.
That's my sanctuary as well.
I literally just redid
mine, cuz I was like,
"This is not good enough."
(both laughing)
Because it's my, like one place,
my little kids I can lock them out of.
- Yeah.
- So, your kids aren't little anymore.
So, they're 19 and 22.
- 22, yeah.
- Okay.
So, how's your relationship
evolved with them?
Just curious.
- Fantastic.
- Yeah.
- It was always been good.
You know, look,
you never quite know
what you're gonna get.
Right?
- Mm hm.
- So, all the best laid plans,
as parenting goes.
- Yeah.
- You never decide to be, you know,
you just give it your best shot.
And then I just lucked out,
because I had, I have two great,
you know, fully well-rounded
good citizens of the
planet kids, you know.
- Yeah.
- Who,
happen as they've got older,
to like to hang with us.
They just like to hang with us.
You know, it's not like,
and so it's just a joy.
- That's rare.
- It's the gift that keeps on giving.
I have to say, I'm just
totally welling up.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Totally blessed.
- Yeah.
That's awesome. That's rare.
Usually kids are like,
"Okay, I want freedom
and I just wanna go do my own thing."
- Yeah.
- That's amazing.
- No, they just, they've
always been like that.
Also, they've always had
their friends come over,
you know, the more the merrier.
Family's really big for us, you know.
- Yeah.
- They've always gone to Wales
to be with my family
since they were toddlers.
I used to send them on the air,
on the, on the, you know
on the airplane to Wales.
You know, like with their
passports around their neck.
- Yeah.
- Those are my kids.
I used to send them off.
They used to have a fantastic time.
Yeah, they still love to travel.
- Yeah, I just, the kind of independence
that must bring though on as a kid
to feel so like, "Oh, I
got to do this by myself."
And my kids would love it.
- Yeah.
- They would be like,
"We're fine. Go away."
(both laughing)
So we've been talking a lot about family.
So, did you have, you know,
a relationship with your mother
how you have with your children?
- Yes, I'm very, very close to my mother,
but not the kind of relationship I think
where, that I have with my kids.
I don't know, it's just,
it's just generational.
- My mom the same.
Like, she's like, it's so funny,
me and my sister are very open
with our kids and we'll
talk about anything.
But my mom, I think
it's a generation thing,
- Yeah.
- cuz she will not,
she is like, "I don't feel like we need
to talk about this or discuss it."
(Catherine laughing)
And I'm like, "What?"
So, that's it, it must
be a generation thing.
- Yeah.
- But was there any advice
you remember getting
from your mom though?
Cuz you were so young, like starting out,
was there any advice she kinda gave you?
- She always said to me,
"You make the most of yourself, Catherine,
cuz you never know when you're gonna meet
the president of the United States.
Okay, cut to like, I'm
living in Wales in a village.
I was never gonna,
the president is not gonna be walking
down in my street anytime soon.
So, I didn't know,
I never knew,
- What an odd thing, yeah.
- what she was talking about.
And I think it was from the
Kennedy years, you know,
I mean Camelot from Britain,
I mean America and the politics
and the president was that kind of,
- Yeah.
- Jackie O,
and you know Jackie,
you know Jackie Kennedy?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- So I, anyway, she always
said that to me, always.
And cut to, funny enough,
the Kennedy Honors,
we were just this past week,
I was helping give Sean his Kennedy Honors
and I was in Washington with Michael.
And that morning he said, "Guess what?
They're putting the decorations up."
A friend of Michael's who works
within the White House,
the Clinton White House,
said we can go and see them
put up the decorations.
I went, "Up my street."
Well, let's start with me getting my hair
and makeup done now,
cuz I'm gonna get ready for the big event.
So, I threw on my sweatpants,
no makeup,
- Oh no.
- hair wet,
baseball cap.
And I'm standing there and they say,
"Do you wanna see the Oval Office?"
Like, "Oh yeah. No. Yeah."
Anyway, I'm in the Oval Office.
I walk, I look out the window
and there's Bill Clinton
in a like lumberjack shirt and blue jeans,
chipping golf balls.
And I go, and then he turns,
and then he's walking towards me.
And all I kept thinking was, "My mother."
(all laughing)
- "My mother told me this would happen."
- "Make the most of yourself,
Catherine, you never..."
And he's walking towards me.
"You never know when you're gonna meet
the president of the United States."
(audience cheering)
And I'm like, "Hi."
Like not trying to make contact.
I probably had sleep in my eyes,
you know, like, "Hello."
Anyway-
- I wish you would've
been like, "It only goes up from here."
- I know. Yeah.
Yeah, "I scrub up well."
Well, anyway, it was
one of those wonderful,
ah, my mum, I love her.
- How random that that ended
up happening in your life?
(Kelly laughing)
- What, where was I, I mean, literally-
- That is funny that she even said it.
I have to say this.
I've already told you, I love "Wednesday."
It is, I don't know if you've seen,
it is so good.
- Thank you.
(audience cheering)
Y'alls family, the
relationships how it played out.
Like, were you excited to do that?
- I was, I mean, Tim Burton called me up.
I was just excited about that.
If it ended there, I
would've been good to go.
(Kelly lagging)
And then he said, you know,
"Do you wanna be part of this?"
And I mean, oh my God, to play like
such an iconic,
- Morticia.
- matriarch of, you know.
- Yeah.
- Generationally, you know,
like my niece subconsciously knows.
- I mean, you're perfect for the role.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- Oh, I was having such a ball.
Yeah, but to play that
with him, it's his vision.
And then, you know, the
amazing performances.
But I've just been lucky this year
that I have two pieces of work coming out
where,
all my kind of MO kind of was fulfilled
in that I got to work with great people,
I got to work with young actors,
a lot of young actors,
- Yeah.
- who were just profoundly professional,
super talented,
- Mm.
- and fun to boot.
- Yeah.
- And at this point in my career, Kelly,
I mean I don't wanna sound like weird,
but everything else is
a bonus now, you know,
- I get that.
- I've had such a,
I'm sure you feel it,
- I get that, yeah.
- You reach that milestones in your life,
and not just professionally I have to say,
just milestones like
when you're a little girl
you dream about those things
and then you go, "Wow,
if it all ended tomorrow
I've just been, I've
had such a great time."
So,
- You're a wonderful thing.
- everything else is a bonus.
And these two pieces of work, "Wednesday"
and "National Treasure"
- And "National Treasure."
Yeah.
- that comes out,
in the next week or so.
It's just been a gift.
- Well, okay, so your other series,
I love this "National
Treasure, Edge of History."
So, it's a part of the
Nicholas Cage franchise
obviously for the movie, right?
- Yes.
- Yeah, the movie.
This Friday.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
- I'm, I like beg to get to see this,
but I didn't get to see this one yet
and I'm so excited about it.
- You will.
Well, if you, another one,
I mean the "National Treasure" franchise
is like part of our
subconscious, you know?
- Yeah.
- When I was,
Jerry Bruckheimer called
me up, the producer,
and said, "Would you wanna
be part of this production?"
I went, "Yes, it sounds great."
And they gave me a kind of
a synopsis of the character
and I went, "Yeah, that
sounds really great."
So, I told my kids, it
was like I told them
this long winded story
about what I was doing next.
They went, "Are you talking
about "National Treasure?"
I went, "Yeah."
They went, "Cool! We
love National Treasure."
So-
- Oh, that's winning as a parent.
- That's so winning.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- And so, yeah.
So, it's one of those again,
that, a great franchise that I get
to kinda come into at
a different character.
- Yeah.
- And it's fun.